we're here I'm happy to go home why so
happy this time good morning believe
nations today the day we're going home
hey hey hey yes
[Applause]
I miss home I want to go home actually
they're going to good week guys yeah
this is some exciting the rush into the
airport behind schedule so here we go
excited it's been a good week we learned
a lot of things we grew as human beings
learn some life lessons right kids right
yeah how do my blessings
how amazing haha and got to get to the
airport got to get some guys didn't need
my coffee
this is hustle and hit home Starbucks
hire more people if we're we go some
explain is crazy hire more people but
I'm gonna have to send it out line
because I love my wife she wants a
coffee so I need to support her hooray
[Music]
look at that smile someone is excited to
have some coffee - where's mine
oh I'm filming you look like a giant cuz
I'm filming you I should mention for 18
I got a carol practice reroute pain oh
yeah you said affording all right time
to Garrity okay there you go
we're here I think you guys are happy we
met so how come let me see you healthy
yeah being good at cricket yes suspected
Macbeth it relaxing yes all right well
here we go
how do you feel
happy alright we made it a little bit
lots of I'm trying to watch the movie on
a phone
in circular but it to be back going to
lose this t-shirt weather soon
it is the both side mm on the ground so
we'll see what it's like but just good
to be home wife is happy to be home
we're going to hop in the car
you'll explain what's cooking even doing
to give home shower yeah I didn't want
to say anything yet but feeling
ninis Telstra's I'm just discussing
power
[Music]
[ __ ] Toronto guys
[Music]
made Louisville we're all matching to
the airplane is very excited
Nina's plants didn't die while we were
away me Matt the plan still look good no
they look better than alive they look
great is it look at this one that's
great I'm excited to go outside
I was really worried that Nina's plants
would die it would make me very sad
because knee would be very sad but these
look great
so it's good to be back shaking off my
headache want to share one final
parenting tip that we picked up the help
the first one I talked about in a
previous video we did one present per
person and they knew actually they knew
they all wanted the Harry Potter wand
before even going so they didn't even
ask yeah they didn't ask the whole time
right the whole time you didn't say I
want this and I want this now is this
that was really good I made that up kind
of four years ago and I think every year
we just made it more and more clear
earlier and earlier and it was that part
was fantastic we didn't get bothered at
all about one in different gifts so that
that's amazing we got to start trying
for that for next year
one gift the other thing that we did
that with new that we made up on the
spot this year was time Addis
so what I did was so in our family we
don't do spanking we do time at it so
you get you get timeouts or misbehaving
any time they misbehave or complain we
give them a minute timeout and then to
get rid of a minute they have to do a
good deed for somebody else
it was look good like we started not
like midway through the vacation I feel
like we're going to start it sooner next
year and maybe ratchet up the points
little faster
but I think we'll work that well they
hate it getting the time out and they
were looking for ways to do you do good
each other people so I'm gonna be
gorgeous
time up yeah so if they had a good seat
before they had minutes
they got negative one minute I think
that worked well good try the next time
anyway
parenting tips from evident Eva so
that's it for us Haven oh this is our
last video what Hayden was a little bit
sad about hearing this is the less you
do gonna make but thank you guys to
joining us on our Florida adventure what
was your favorite part guys was your
favorite part Studios Universal Studios
Universal Studios pretty good I also
like the Simpsons live dr. Ramel we call
those the the graphics was very good the
3d graphic for you I like being able to
have humongous Starbucks drinks every
day second I miss that sometimes twice
and with that and spending time with my
family
yeah right we'll take you guys to
joining we believe in you we hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is Aquarius and
much love guys much laughs I